For better or for us people should get to know what happened
after the fall of his business empire.
Sam Baman freed,
once seen as the golden boy of crypto is about to go on trial.
He is accused of basically lying to his customers,
lying to his investors and lying to lenders about what FX was
doing with customer funds.
On October 3rd,
Beman Freed's trial on charges that he defrauded customers of billions of dollars will
begin in a New York federal court.
He has pleaded not guilty to all criminal charges.
Here's what you need to know about the case and the man on trial
at 30 years old in 2022 Sam Bank been freed had founded two
successful companies,
a trading firm called Alameda Research.
He started in 2017 and a $32 billion Cryptocurrency exchange
called FX.
That came two years later,
FX and Alameda Research were run by an inner circle of Sam and his closest friends and
colleagues,
Caroline Ellison,
who was the Ceo of Alameda Research.
Gary Wang,
who is a co founder of FX and responsible for much of its technology.
And Nasha Singh,
who is the director of engineering at FX.
The upper management all lived together in a luxury penthouse in the Bahamas that cost
$30 million.
Bank Fried was also a familiar face in the political scene on Capitol Hill in
February 2022.
He testified at a Senate hearing where he encouraged better regulation of Cryptocurrency
markets.
It is the patchwork of regulation that there is simultaneously too
many cooks in the kitchen and yet not enough oversight.
Bank Fried personally made $40 million in donations ahead of the 2022
midterm elections.
At one point,
he was estimated to have a net worth of $15.6 billion.
He was one of the biggest richest and most successful people in crypto until last year when everything
collapsed in November 2022.
A report from crypto website,
Coindesk revealed that most of Alameda S assets were in Fx's tokens
setting off a run but FX wasn't able to meet the billions of dollars of
withdrawals.
Bank man Fried stepped down as CEO and shortly after FX filed for
bankruptcy in traditional finance regulators require brokerages to
segregate customer funds from any capital they use for trading.
Cryptocurrency is still considered the wild west where the rules are.
Murkier.
This is one of the biggest financial frauds in American history.
Fried was arrested in mid December in the Bahamas after the US filed criminal charges including
wire fraud and conspiracy to commit money laundering.
Prosecutors are saying that he stole money from FX customers
to use for various purposes including campaign donations and charitable
causes.
When that money should have been safe and secure at FX.
Less than a year later,
he's about to face a jury and his former inner circle Caroline Ellison,
Gary Wang and Nasha Singh.
All three have pleaded guilty to fraud charges and are expected to testify against
bank freed.
Caroline's testimony will probably be very important in this trial because
she was the head of Alameda research and she would have been closer to the
actual trading strategies and Alameda investments than Sam was.
So she would be in a position to say yes,
we took this money and used it for these purposes and knew that we were doing it.
And here this is what was Sam's role in that and Beman Fried could take the stand
himself.
Sam is no ordinary defendant after the collapse of FX.
He gave a whole lot of interviews.
Tweeted started a sub stack and tried to defend himself publicly.
So he might be inclined to try and testify in his own defense.
In an interview with the journal last December Bank Fried said he bore responsibility for the
company's collapse but did not knowingly commit any fraud.
I don't think that I did.
You know,
I don't think I tried to commit fraud anywhere here.
I was trying to do the best I could.
Obviously,
that wasn't nearly as good as I thought it was Bank Fried could
face up to decades in prison if he's found guilty.
And he has a trial for additional conspiracy and fraud charges.
Tentatively scheduled for March 2024.
The securities and exchange commission and commodity futures trading Commission also have
pending civil suits against Bank Fried.
Think people in the crypto industry now want to sort of say,
ok,
that happened,
but we're moving on.
It will also be a landmark move for prosecutors and the government
as they try to regulate and control crypto,
they'll be able to say,
look,
if you run a big fraudulent enterprise,
we will come after you and put you in jail.